vamos a multiplicar por 10 100 y 1000 ya
que tendremos un patrón bastante bueno
que surge con esto comencemos con 4 por
10 que es sencillo y ya conocemos 4 por
10 es lo mismo que decir 4 decenas y una
forma de representar cuatro decenas es
decir aquí hay un 10 más otro 10 más
otro 10 más otro 10 o 4 veces 10
vamos a contar esto 10 + 10 es 20 + 10
30 + 10 40 así que nuestra solución es
40 o un 4 con un cero al final y este es
el patrón que hemos visto antes cuando
multiplicamos 4 por 10
mantenemos nuestro número entero que es
4 y le agregamos un 0 al final y esto es
cuando multiplicamos por 10 otro ejemplo
sería 8 veces 10 y 8 por 10 8 veces 10
es lo mismo que 8 decenas y en este caso
vamos a contarlas
20 30 40 50 60 70 80 así que cuando
cuento ocho decenas la solución
es 80 o 18 con un cero al final así que
cuando multiplicamos un número entero
por 10 el patrón es que vamos a agregar
un cero al final de este número vamos a
tomar lo que ya conocemos sobre las
decenas y vamos a aplicarlos con las
centenas algo como 2% hay un par de
formas en las que podemos pensar en esto
una de ellas es decir que esto es igual
que dos centenas
es una centena más otras centenas que es
literalmente dos centenas es un total de
200 o 12 con dos ceros al final ahora
tenemos dos ceros al final otra forma de
pensar en ello es decir dos por y en
lugar de decir que multiplicamos por 100
decimos que multiplicamos por 10 por 10
ya que 10 veces 10 es lo mismo que una
centena y 2 por 10 es 20 el 2 con el 0
al final y 20 por 10 será 20 con 10 al
final ya que multiplicamos por 10 dos
veces le agregamos dos ceros al final y
multiplicar por 100 es justamente esto
multiplicamos por 10 dos veces así que
si al multiplicar por 10 agregamos un 0
al final puedes al multiplicar por 100 o
al multiplicar por 10 dos veces
agregar a dos ceros al final ahora
podemos ir más allá y pensar en miles
ahora multipliquemos 9 por mil podemos
pensar en esto como nueve veces mil y si
tenemos nueve veces mil vamos a tener
mil dos mil 3.000 4.000 5.000 6.000 7000
8000 y 9000 así que si contamos mil
nueve veces nuestra solución es nueve
mil y si vemos los números tenemos al
nueve nuestro número original con tres
ceros al final así que 9 por mil es 9000
o un nueve con tres ceros y si
regresamos a lo que vimos antes pensando
en esto en términos de múltiplos de 10
pensemos en este mil en términos de
multiplicaciones de 10.000 es igual a 10
x 10 x 10
10 x 10 es 100 y 100 veces 10 es 1000
así que en lugar de tener 1000 podemos
escribir 10 x 10 x 10 son equivalentes y
cuando multiplicamos un número por 10
tenemos este número con un 0 al final
pero aquí lo estamos multiplicando por
tres veces 10 así que le agregamos 3
ceros al final veamos esto como un solo
patrón pongamos el número 7 y lo vamos a
multiplicar por 10 por 100 y por 1.000
vamos a ver qué pasa
7 por 10 va a ser el 7 con un cero al
final ya que lo multiplicamos por un 10
7 veces 100 va a ser igual a un 7 con
dos ceros al final porque 100 es igual a
10 por 10 así que este es un 7 x 10 2
veces le agregamos dos ceros y 7 por mil
es igual a este 7 con tres ceros al
final ya que este mil es lo mismo que
tener 10
por 10 por 10 o 3 veces 10 así que
tendremos 3 ceros podemos ver el patrón
de que cuando multiplicamos por 10 que
tiene un 0 le agregaremos un 0 al final
de nuestro número entero cuando tenemos
un número que lo multiplicamos por 100
que tiene dos ceros le agregaremos dos
ceros al final de este número y cuando
multiplicamos por mil que tiene tres
ceros le agregaremos tres ceros al final
a este número entero